[Music]
i'm gonna go three two one after one
everybody just point to the [ __ ]
hottest wildest guy in the room all
right
three two one
wow thanks everyone wow dude unanimous
everybody died dude anthony is number
two though he's welcome to an exciting
off the record here of the careful boys
today we've got ron back in the house
uh zero percent white yeah there it is
okay okay
we want to hear from the really really
hot and wild guy in the room for a quick
second what's up ryan what's up man uh
what's up man thanks for having me
reporting from this side
glad to be here just in from the third
table of the room
while joe's putting bottle caps on his
nipple
i'm trying to be presentable for this
show
that's half of it's out what is that a
nip slip do we have to censor that yeah
you do you get some pasties man oh my
gosh christ
i am attracted to it can't stop looking
oh there it is okay we're back hey
we're back we're [ __ ] not right now
no i was just saying that there's some
crazy [ __ ] that happened to me the other
uh over the weekend actually
i was uh so ryan of you i know it's just
just my luck i was who died
i don't know yet if anyone died oh [ __ ]
so like uh
i had just eaten at perch which is like
a restaurant in downtown it's like a
good restaurant yeah yeah yeah so um
it's over on uh hill street
and uh oh is it like a rooftop yeah oh
i've been there yeah so then i was
getting you know you gotta like it's
easy to valet your car there when you go
there so i validate it
and then um when the valets brought it
back after like uh dinner was over and
everything i'm coming down the valet
parks it along the curb just like normal
nothing weird at all uh me and my
girlfriend and her mom we all get in the
car as i'm about to shut the door
a car just comes through and bashes it
off out of my life
out of my hand out of your head yeah so
you're doing the clothes like that and
it went wow and it just goes
and it's some dude just like a
challenger like just went through and
just hit it was a [ __ ] challenge and
your hand's okay yeah dude that's why
the disney it was so close to my hand
bro it just went
bad and then [ __ ] and i just felt it
like come back
and then um and then it was just stuck
so i was like what the [ __ ] and then it
didn't even
all the way forward so it like it bent
the whole thing what kind of car do you
think were you driving back just uh
accord 2009.
thank god it wasn't one of the cords
yeah so this challenge that challenger
it just instantly drives off and he's
just doing this all throughout the road
and i think he hit some other [ __ ] and
then he just kept going he was just gone
oh he's like drunk as [ __ ] he's on
quality something and they're not even
fast enough where he can like take a
photo or nothing it was just like out of
there was everyone like oh my god yeah
everyone in the street was like what the
[ __ ] was that because that [ __ ] was so
so i wasn't even um there's like a line
to show whether or not you're in the
next lane or not and that line was way
the [ __ ] over there so it wasn't like
our car was too close so they just
leered off they just went over too far
and they just hit the [ __ ] off and then
so um i immediately like did a police
report i called and i was like yo this
guy hit my car and then he just boned
out uh
black dodge challengers all i could
remember and then um of course you know
like when you call they just it seems
like nothing's gonna happen especially
la yeah the the person on the line's
like okay well you know we'll try but
you can really just file it online it's
especially what happens i was like oh
[ __ ] we need [ __ ] mike lowry to show
up and we want the helicopters to
[ __ ] chase them
i know and so like i i even was like so
for perch i'm like the the um security
downstairs that saw it happen they were
like oh we got cameras here so they
probably got it and i was like oh
perfect it happened 10 59 on the dot and
then i they were like yeah you just got
to come back tomorrow and then uh
they'll just give it to you i came back
the next day and they didn't give it to
me they were like we're not allowed to
release it it has to go to police and
then so um
i call security mexican
i don't even know because the mexican
ones are tight
oh [ __ ] yeah i'll get the [ __ ]
surveillance here
i think it's one of the things where
they want to just give it to the person
because they could just upload it and
then make bad press for the place i
don't know
either way the police calls me they
called me back
and then they actually investigated it
they're like hey we got the guy
i was like i was like no [ __ ] away
but then um
they go we can't release his info to you
yet because we're still investigating
the guy who hit you claims that he was
being shot at and that's why he was
driving that way
oh
[ __ ] yeah so they were like
how many other cars did he hit
so there were no other cars on the road
there was no other noise there was no
gunshot sounds the cops were asking me
like we need to find out if that's true
so did you guys hear gunshots are there
any bullet holes on your car or anything
around you did anyone say that there
were gunshots happening none of that
stuff zero of it
so i don't know i think he just closed
your door you know what were you able to
close your door oh i couldn't close it
after so but he just admitted that he'd
hit your door regardless of purpose i
don't know if he admitted it they just
they caught him because he fit the
description of the same [ __ ] guy that
was probably hitting other [ __ ] and then
my time stamp and everything just
matched and this position that we were
in and everything was just this guy just
knows how to play the game with the cops
yeah i guess he's just he's saying that
someone was shooting at him but there
was a hundred percent no does that put
you off the hook though if you're like i
was getting shot at so i had to drive
like i think it escalated so now
whatever crime you're reporting doesn't
matter anymore right so now they have to
treat this
and that's why his his objective was to
just get information from me on whether
or not there was like gunfire and and so
like that kind of delays the whole like
like give me his [ __ ] info so i can
tell my insurance you know but then uh
now the insurance is saying that like oh
you just have to
get you you have to get the police
report from the lapd and then that
should have the info on it and then and
then i turn that into insurance it's
like more [ __ ] i have to do
the police reports only if you want to
file a claim that's it
i can do anything else that's just how
it is now you know that happened to me
outside of uh
so when early jk we're taking like
improv classes at upright citizens
brigade in offline fairfax right and
then i'm like walking back to my car and
um
i get in my car and i think i was gonna
get something from the trunk or
something like that and uh
i barely opened it like an inch
and this car comes and just knocks the
uh the [ __ ] door like just like or
swings it all the way open right
and then i was like oh [ __ ] usually i'm
the type of person
that like i'm like probably the opposite
of nick you know nick jumps in the car
and drives off
i'm like i open the door and i get out
like it's one it's swiftly one motion
that's usually how i operate right
i do that too bro oh really yeah but
this time i just
uh for some reason i opened the door a
little bit first and as soon as i opened
it an inch it [ __ ] hits my door then
one of my classmates she's like oh my
god i saw exactly what happened this
lady was driving through the street and
just looking at houses and just started
veering off nice and then ended up
hitting my car on my sick i got a
[ __ ] witness my car is parked [ __ ]
close and shut case right
we ended up going to the insurance and
by the way after after class when i
drove home when i'm driving on the
freeway i have to hold the [ __ ] door
shut because it won't even close anymore
later on i found out that it was my
fault because i opened my car door into
traffic
what and i'm like but i have a [ __ ]
witness saying that this lady
uh was looking and then [ __ ] drifting
off and i was still wrong oh no it's
probably how you told the story got to
pay for my car they probably looked at
this and their car no
it's his fault
for sure
open the door middle of the road you
would do that so if you kept your door
closed and she just crashed into your
head it would have been fine but she
could like if i got out the way i
normally get out my legs would have been
broken oh my god you would have to pay
for it yeah it would have been your
fault that's [ __ ] crazy you could say
it would be it depends on the insurance
carrier too as well some insurance
carriers like the big ones like state
farm mercury they'll take care of it
like around the back they'll have your
side but it's another company adriana's
you know
here you go
um they'll fight to the bitter end so
they don't have to pay out i got geico
or like i just dealt with that like
literally like a month ago i uh i let i
let my mother-in-law borrow my truck and
she was driving a dude cutter off as she
was turning right into a plaza cut her
off and then she ended up
hitting his
side rear quarter panel which would only
happen if he
made an illegal
turn and uh
you know he admitted fault everything
like that and then
everything was cool then also he said
something else to the insurance company
he said it wasn't my fault this was in
the middle of the street i'm like dude i
have a picture
of
your car
literally
stopped and hitting the other car not in
the middle of the street yeah um and
then they fought back and forth and
ended up being the insurance saying well
we've decided that it's a zero fault and
then my insurance company sorry they
they are contesting it multiple times uh
there's nothing we can do unless you
want to take this to court i'm like are
you serious wow i'm like fudge no
justice in the world man and it's
because their insurance was the cheap
one or your their insurance was fighting
it hard
and the cheap insurance ones yeah cheap
insurance one
yeah yeah so maybe i should just get
cheap and
go fight harder yeah so in my end since
it was no fault i had to pay deductible
and then get all these all these things
fixed so i had to pay like 500 bucks wow
for that i hope that doesn't happen with
me man so that's [ __ ] [ __ ] so now
your car you can't even drive it i can't
drive it because the door won't close is
that do you legally need a door though
yeah you can't drive with your door open
but what about them jeeps that [ __ ]
have like nothing well those those are
classified differently i think you can't
drive a four door on a cord with an open
door can we pull up can we pull up some
information confirming this i would
really love to see a doorless honda
accord rolling around oh you mean if i
just took the door off completely yeah
just take it off just unbolt it just put
a net yeah yeah cause you know jeeps
have that net that's what's gonna say
like just put a tommy boy picket fence
hondas are actually one of the most easy
to steal cars too you kind of need the
door
i mean that too i kind of don't want to
drive it around where you could just get
in oh like some other person you just
put like a viper alarm on it just have a
homeless guy taking a [ __ ] in it oh my
god
oh my gosh dude
this is for a production you could
totally ride around the street like this
how sick is that
so don't you're just like yo dude i'm
filming right now all right don't pull
me over just put a camera on top
avoiding some kind of like thing that
would happen to me like if i got an
accident with no door i would it would
be fault at fault or good
we just found a picture of it today's
video is brought to you by audible
so now that i live in hawaii
my trips are getting longer and longer
um so my flights are about five hours
long and i'm like how can i be
productive during this time thanks to
audible where i could choose one title a
month uh i am now listening to set the
table setting the table it is this
massive successful restaurant who wrote
this whole entire book and um you know
i'm gonna be opening up junebe very soon
in honolulu so i'm getting all the info
that i can that's gonna help me that's
gonna educate me and audible is my
gateway to doing that that's dope yeah
audible has all kinds of stuff there
you're a one-stop shop for your
listening entertainment they got
podcasts they got books audiobooks
obviously they also have shows they got
com they got all kinds of stuff and you
get to check out one title every single
month so if you got long trips like joe
oremy
it's definitely an app you want to
download let audible help you discover
new ways to laugh be inspired or be
entertained new members can try it free
for 30 days visit audible.com off the
record or text off the record to
500-500 that's audible.com off the
record or text off the record to 500-500
to try audible free for 30 days
audible.com off the record i don't know
if i told you guys this story before but
um one time i i had my civic parked
outside my place and then some honda
element came and just
like crashed into it and drove off david
that's why i sold it
i had it on camera and everything but i
i didn't know like uh
i couldn't get a license plate or
anything so i was like freaking out
and then uh
finally i did get a plate i went i went
door-to-door neighbor to neighbor to try
to figure out like if anybody got a shot
on their camera all these people
couldn't get it one house i'm just on
the intercom and i'm like hey bro like
uh i'm your neighbor from down the
street a car hit my car when it was
parked i wondered if you got an angle of
the uh of the license plate and the dude
on the other side it's like oh yeah dude
i got you just give me the time stamp
i'll give it to you i was like that's
dope so i gave my email he just sent it
to me
turns out it's [ __ ] um
what's that guy's name adam devine no
way
he lived five houses down the
workaholics guy and he hit you and he
gave it to him yeah no no no not the guy
who hit him the guy who gave the [ __ ]
the guy who gave me the footage was it
wow what a nice guy how did you know it
was him because his name on his email is
adam divine and he's just pictures what
could have been well he's part of our
neighborhood uh collective like our
whole like neighborhood watch email list
and then everybody was like saying yeah
he's cool he totally like lives right
there with his wife like chloe bridges
or whatever that sounds crazy but i just
never see him so i didn't know it was
him holy [ __ ] yeah and then so he gives
me the good neighbor he gives me the
plate and then obviously like
uh
i wanted to find out who did it like i
was pissed so
my buddy at the time there's a long time
ago this is another wild grind moment
huh it actually it actually very much is
my buddy at the time how to connect at
the dmv you give a plate he can get the
the phone number the address everything
so allegedly yeah so he gave it to me
i'm like i'm so i'm pretty pissed
because this person just took off so i
can't wait to i go to the address it's
like up the hill from my house oh so i'm
like oh when i get right there
so mad i get over there i see the
element parked in the like with the tarp
halfway on it it's all [ __ ] up oh my
getting my car and i'm like oh this
person is going to get it i knock on the
door it's this like cute little old lady
she's the one that hit you yeah kicked
your [ __ ] ass right yeah and then i
was like i was like um it's not a guy my
toughness just like i was like
do you know why i'm here ma'am
[Laughter]
but like in my head that line was
supposed to come out way cooler but
instead i was like oh man do you know
why i'm here and she was like oh no what
is it what can i help you with and then
she's like um i'm like you hit my car
the other day like
don't you realize that you hit my car
you drove away and she's like oh i was
just so like flustered they had they had
done a detour and it's true like that
day they were doing a detour where all
these people had to go through my street
instead of take laurel cannon so
everyone was like being weird and then
um
and she would and this is what she said
she goes
oh you know my husband who died we have
a car that we don't need anymore because
he's gone and passed on so you can have
it if you like and she pointed to like a
a civic chest like mine
what yeah and she goes she goes it's
okay with me if you take it it'll just
sit there anyway and i felt so bad
because like it was true she's like this
little old lady that's like a retired
nurse living in her house by herself was
she filipino by chance no she was white
she was completely white and i was just
like
so i was like it's okay just like
i was like as long as you have insurance
we could just go through that you don't
get it and she closes the door and then
she goes to her son i am never gonna
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] for you ever
yeah that's a sick mom yeah it's really
sweet one time i did that without
knowing i was driving down the lane so i
had the blue truck and i was just
driving i remember uh going north on the
atlantic i don't know where maybe the
passenger or something and then it go i
hear this
what the [ __ ] was that it sounded like
[ __ ] someone shot at me or whatever
and i'm looking at my tire pressure i'm
okay cool
okay i didn't have a blow a tire or
anything i'm like that's good and i go
do whatever and i finally go home
and then i i park the car and i go
outside i'm like oh someone bashed my
side mirror that's [ __ ] up but then i
started thinking about it and i'm like
no i ran into someone's car and that car
knocked on my side mirror
but i don't even know
i was probably [ __ ] like driving and
texting or some [ __ ] and then i went
dude i'm
[Laughter]
wow
i'm so sorry there was a detour
somebody turned
just hitting up the cops somebody was
shooting at me that's why i was driving
like that but that's why the dodge
challenger thought someone was shooting
at him when he crashed into the full
circle
look at this guy
could be he's like someone was shooting
at me right outside of the purse
can you believe it
dude that [ __ ] sucks man oh my god
holy [ __ ] you hit that's so [ __ ]
funny just in the beginning of the video
just being like there's no guns there's
no bullets why would that person say it
what [ __ ] loser
it's just the sound of hitting my doria
you know on atlantic uh where that 76 uh
gas station is
everyone's cars parked on the street you
know it's a hill and arrow so it's a
two-lane street and it's one of those
where like you can't if the margin of
error is so low right right if you're
texting and drive you better be really
good so much gun violence on this
dude shootings every day to be fair that
lady that hit me she did say that she
tried to uh find what she hit but she
couldn't and it to be fair it is really
confusing because if you're going
through this detour through the
hollywood hills and everyone's beeping
at you to continue forward she probably
later on just couldn't figure out where
she was because it's so confusing so i
was like i'll give you a pass she's
super old too the older they are the
wiser she knew she probably don't have
gps she was there before they built the
house she was there before honda
elements existed live no civics not even
mine
my neighbor's car idiot
the loss is hers because honda elements
are supposed to keep their values pretty
high but she just [ __ ] yeah that one
just [ __ ] her out i love lmc they're
sick they are pretty cool
i was i was not liking them for that day
though i was looking around at every
honda element and i even got on my
motorcycle and i patrolled the area and
i saw a honda element that had a bashed
side and i thought that was the guy and
i went alongside him and i was taking
photos of his license and it wasn't even
him he do it in the car bro so free
cause it was in the middle of night and
i was like on a vendetta dude i kept
asking if your security guard was
mexican because they're usually the cool
ones yeah we're nice to live in downtown
uh this is when like everyone was trying
to do like the casey neistat style vlogs
right so i'm like oh for today's b-roll
i'm gonna fly my drone around the
[ __ ] like skyscrapers and stuff yeah
and then um i was still learning how to
fly it
and then it had i had it like maybe four
feet away from our building
and then a gust of wind comes and it
just blows the drone into the building
boom and the drone flies straight down
and it's like on like we lived on a
olympic and figure or so it's like
downtown downtown and i just see my
[ __ ] drone like
like that boom and i'm like i hope it
doesn't hit a car hoping to hit a car
because you know it's like packed around
there
it hits the ground didn't hit a car i'm
like cool no one's hurt so i rush down
and when i rush down i'm like oh shoot
the bug
i'm like just looking around trying to
play it cool you know because obviously
when something flies from like the 30th
floor it's loud as [ __ ] and then the
security guard like the guy that's like
the valet dude with the best he could
tell that i was looking for something
like hey
you looking for something
i was like yeah he goes what are you
looking for i was like
a drone
oh [ __ ] that was yours dude come over
here
and he brought it out for me he said he
said the minute he saw it he went and
grabbed it and snatched it up because he
didn't know like if it was a crime
yeah he was just like damn that guy's
down because if dude if that thing
landed and like if cops came i could
have been like i don't know endangerment
to society or some [ __ ] like that but he
probably would have went to jail for
that yeah he got all my parts
out of you you're thinking that this
guy's watching your back he's like oh my
[ __ ] selfies right now
yeah but he scooped it up from the
street and he gave it to me i'm like
that's dope man so cool man
he's an accomplice and he doesn't even
know like he could have been a part of a
[ __ ] terrorist plot and he doesn't
even know he loses his job
dude my worst nightmare would have been
like it [ __ ] lands on someone's
windshield or like or a second head or a
baby stroller oh
dude
with a baby in it that ought to be your
worship
a baby stroller full of cans dude
a lot of change man
[Music]